dr nash in total transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transferring lives all across the valley
and today she joins us to discuss a very
common trouble area
dr nash it's great to see you and today
we're talking about something that many
of us deal with and that is
belly fat and it seems like belly fat is
so hard to get rid of is belly fat
different than other fat in our body
yeah you know that thing that we notice
when we're trying to lose weight and it
seems like the belly's not responding
you're right it is actually different
and the reason that it's different in
the belly area is because it's not just
driven by calories but it's actually
driven more by issues with the
metabolism underneath what are some
metabolism issues that we're dealing
with so we can attack those and get rid
of the belly fat
right so
the problem is most people don't even
necessarily know what metabolism is so
metabolism is the biochemical reactions
in the body that can slow down or stop
fat loss even when you're eating less
and even when you're moving more and so
there's several that can affect the
midsection and cause belly fat but the
common three are going to be
inflammation a hormone imbalance a
dietary hormone imbalance and fatty
liver do you have any examples you want
to show us as far as a client that has a
great success with losing belly fat yeah
actually we're going to take a look at
meredith meredith did my program in may
of 2020 so this was at the height of the
lockdowns everything was shut down the
only thing she could do is walk for
exercise but when we look at her before
and after picture if you look at that
belly specifically the belly in the
before picture was quite distended and
that's because she had metabolic damage
she couldn't burn fat properly and after
she went through the program now that
was being corrected she's burning body
fat at about 75 percent of the time and
that belly just leaned right out the
photo is amazing it's two it's two
different women right there that we're
looking at it's
incredible those results yeah and it
really really is and to know that she
did that during the lockdowns when
activity was restricted when the only
kind of activity she could do is walk
well that's good news for all of us who
might still be nervous about going out
to the gym or we just don't have access
to some kind of activity or equipment
now are these results typical for your
clients
they are typical if people do what i ask
them to do so every program that i build
is a customized program based on their
specific issues but if people who are
watching are noticing that they either
gained a significant amount of weight in
the belly or they've always struggled
with that it's probably a good idea to
take advantage of that evaluation find
what's going on and every week you bring
a special with you what's special to
have for us this week i do so normally
my evaluations are 97 but if you tell if
you actually go online to drnash.com
forward slash eval we have 10 spots
available right now that are 90 off
you're gonna be able to do that online
evaluation one-on-one with me for just
9.97 that's awesome dr nash we always
appreciate you coming on
you're changing lives across the valley
these specials are fantastic thanks for
joining us this week we appreciate it
you bet thank you so much jc always good
to be here
a big thank you to total transformation
for sponsoring this segment visit
drnash.com forward slash eval to take
advantage of her special offer las vegas
now we'll be right back